y jair bolsonaro lleva ya un año
negándose a las medidas más
significativas para bajar los contagios
una postura más hacia la prevención cree
usted habría marcado la diferencia y más
aún se podrían revertir la gravedad de
la pandemia en brásil
sin duda yo creo que sin duda o sea que
el presidente sea el primer a decir que
la gente no debe aislarse no debe hacer
como hizo las campañas en contra de la
vacuna y rechazar ofertas de vacuna de
empresas género y es una parte
fundamental de la crisis sanitaria que
pasa brasil hoy no bueno sin embargo hay
que decirlo que el argumento de
bolsonaro tampoco es superficial es
cuando él dice que el hambre mata más
que el cob y eso es cierto pero utilizar
mascarilla tampoco es difícil ni es
descabellado tiene razón bolsonaro en
pedir a la gente que regrese al trabajo
no creo que hay dos cosas una cosa es
sin duda reforzar el punto del
aislamiento de mascarilla y todo eso que
él no hace al contrario hace todo
encontrar sale crea aglomeraciones
genera y un poco a hacer hace poco y ha
dicho muchas veces que la enfermedad no
es tan grave ya ha hecho publicidad de
de tratamiento de medicamentos que no
funcionan no hay mucha gente claro
confía en presidente de ascender eso es
una cosa y es muy grave otra cosa claro
es notar que hay una gente que quiere
trabajar y que hay una crisis económica
y hay dos cosas hay una necesidad de
programas sociales no de reforzar y el
presidente si en el primer año ha hecho
un programa social importante por
presión del congreso ahora
el pregón social está mucho más pequeño
y la crisis es mucho más grave y eso es
también un problema entonces
en lugar de mirar y pensar con programas
sociales como dar condición a la gente
de sobrevivir a la crisis decir que la
gente simplemente les cumpla las medidas
de cierre de los gobernadores es muy
peligroso pero claro el presidente está
hablando como sentimiento que es
legítimo de la gente que quiere trabajar
y que está viviendo periodo de crisis
pero yo creo que un jefe de estado
debería ser más prudente y trabajar en
conjunto con los obradores que están
intentando lidiar con más triste muy muy
grave los hospitales
y sanitaria en el país